well let's uh bring in david uh
weinstein who's a former uh assistant
u.s attorney for the southern district
of florida thank you very much indeed
uh for joining us uh as a legal brain
what's your assessment
do any of these uh suits being launched
by the trump campaign have any merit
they have all a long shot to get
anywhere here
remember uh the issues that are
presented and what's going to get this
up to the supreme court are going to be
the issue of the recount
as far as the recounts go it's not even
close in any of these states certainly
not within a margin of error
his demands in michigan that they'd be
allowed to view as well as in
pennsylvania that they'd be allowed to
view the recounts
they're not even recounts at this point
they're just counting the ballots so
the legs that they have to stand on are
very shaky at this point
do they have a right to a recount in any
of the states
well certainly in those states where the
margin of victory
is uh in some states less than one
percent others less than
half a percent they have a right to a
recount but
the margins that we're seeing across the
board even if he
succeeds in a recount or even in these
recounts he's not going to get the swing
that he needs
to accumulate enough votes to get the
states he needs to push him over the top
so it's going to prove fruitful in the
end and
quite frankly given the fact of how
close things are and not even get itself
up to the supreme court as we saw
back in the gore versus bush
so i mean what's the point then of rudy
giuliani
and and others other republicans
launching these challenges
it comes down to something that we've
seen before certainly from this
administration it's not so much about
the legal merit of the issues but
a pr campaign the rhetoric that this
president has been promoting throughout
is that there was fraud in this election
that the election was stolen from him
by continuing to present this viewpoint
by making these legal challenges
it's providing a rationale for his base
to take his message
forward after he loses this election and
promote a rhetoric that says that this
was not a just result but quite frankly
that's not what's happening here there
was an overwhelming number of votes
in the popular election and then that
converts to
the electoral college votes that are
going to be needed necessary
for former vice president biden to win
this election
is there also a risk that donald trump
could actually alienate
you know some conservative and
republican
supporters by this type of behavior
well there's certainly that risk that
exists um
it hasn't happened before and it hasn't
happened to this point
uh people who are died in the wools
supporters of him are going to
buy into the rhetoric that he's putting
forward but
there may be some people who simply feel
that is enough is enough
and that this election was conducted
fairly that every person's vote counts
and those votes that were in place at
the time that they were due to be put in
place
should be counted so to some degree yes
it may alienate
some of the conservative factor that's
behind him but
in reality those who believe in him are
going to continue to believe in him
despite what the truth brings forward
okay well let's just make the assumption
it's only an assumption
uh for the state of argument that joe
biden does end up
next president the 46th president of the
united states
where does donald trump a controversial
figure stand
legally then we know that there was an
attempt to impeach him
but do you think he is like to face
prosecutions
well there are a number of prosecutors
who are still investigating
allegations against him those include
state prosecutors those include federal
prosecutors
those investigations will move forward
and once he leaves
office he will no longer have that cloak
of protection of being the chief
executive officer
and those prosecutions can proceed
forward so
he's going to find himself in a
situation where he is finally going to
have to answer some of the questions
that have been posed
and he may very well find himself in a
legal battle where we're not just
talking about money anymore
but we're talking about life and liberty
as a result of
allegations of criminal violations he
can though
can he not give himself as well as his
family but give himself
uh some kind of presidential pardon
well you know that's an interesting
question and one that's certainly been
examined them and looked at
you can't pardon yourself and the prime
example of that
is president nixon he was pardoned by
president ford you can't preemptively
pardon yourself for what's going on you
can perhaps do that not even perhaps
you can do that for other people but the
way that the clause is written into our
constitution
you can't pardon yourself
and what i read i don't know whether
you'll confirm this is that the
southern district of manhattan uh a
well-known
uh ferocious uh prosecutor's office that
probably uh is gonna be the biggest
cause of legal trouble for mr trump
no you're absolutely right the southern
district of new york where he tried to
replace the
chief prosecutor there was someone of
his own liking and that didn't succeed
those are the people who have been
looking perhaps the hardest and have him
under the
brightest light at the moment and that's
going to be where things pivot back
around to
uh once he leaves office
do we know what the uh sort of charges
there might be
well you know there have been
allegations with regard to
both tax law violations campaign finance
violations
and other wire fraud matters
but you know until we see something that
comes out it's all speculation at this
point
the grand jury proceedings that have
been taking place are certainly uh
shrouded by the secrecy that's allowed
them to proceed forward so
we can speculate all we want but until
we see something that actually comes out
from that grand jury
we'll have no firm answer
well so far he's uh still the president
so we shall see thank you very much
indeed
uh david weinstein for joining us you're
welcome adam my pleasure to
join you